the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video well my friends i was
definitely wrong about when we would get
our first official teaser from hbo i was
not expecting this to drop so soon but
boy am i glad it did now for those of
you who don't know hbo released their
first official teaser for house of the
dragon only a few hours ago house of the
dragon will be set hundreds of years
before the events of game of thrones
this new series will mostly focus on
house targaryen during what is known as
the dance of dragons this was when house
targaryen fought each other over the
iron throne but in this new show we will
see so much more than just that
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again now let's go through each
of the new images so i can give you my
thoughts on what we will see
it begins with us seeing daemon
targaryen walking through what looks
like the dungeons of either the red keep
in king's landing or maybe even
dragonstone i honestly think this is the
red keep where we have seen the dragon
skulls before in game of thrones the
next thing we see is daemon and rhaenyra
standing on the beach i think this might
be dragonstone here now for those of you
that don't know daemon is the brother of
king viserys targaryen the first of his
name and the woman he is standing next
to is rhaenyra who is the daughter of
king viceros now although daemon is
rhinera's uncle they still enter into a
romantic relationship with one another i
mean this is the way of house targaryen
after all they are not afraid of getting
some dragon on dragon action if you know
what i mean
the next thing we see is a massive
dragon skull sitting above a bunch of
candles
now this might also be inside of the red
keep in king's landing then we see the
hand of the king and i think this is
most likely serato hightower since it
looks like he is wearing green
like i said serato hightower is the hand
of the king but he is also the father of
allison hightower the future wife of
king viserys you see king viserys will
name his daughter rhaenyra as his heir
for the iron throne he does this because
he's not able to have any sons with his
first wife emma aaron after his first
wife dies he eventually marries the
young alison hightower who will give him
children in the years to follow now
what's interesting about this is allison
does give viserys a son but vasaris
doesn't name the sun as his heir he
actually leaves rhaenyra as the heir for
the iron throne but this little issue is
what eventually leads to the dance of
dragons as soon as viserys dies alison
will crown their son aegon the second of
his name before rhaenyra has a chance to
seize the iron throne for herself this
is what eventually leads to an all-out
war among house targaryen the next thing
we see in the teaser trailer is king
viserys targaryen sitting on the iron
throne i love those dragon wings on his
sword by the way
after this we see a young rhinera
targaryen standing in front of the iron
throne this is also who viserys wanted
to take the iron throne after him but as
i just said his new wife alicent will
not allow that to happen after he dies
rhaenyra will have to fight for what she
believes is rightfully hers next we see
the same image as we saw before only
from a different angle this is once
again daemon and rhaenyra only this is
the older version of rhinera i also
think this is them on dragonstone but i
can't say for sure
then we see some soldiers dressed in the
targaryen armor most likely during the
games at some tournament i think this
looks absolutely incredible i might add
i love those dragon wings on the helmets
as well then we see lord corliss
velaryon the man at the head of the
largest fleet in westeros lord corliss
velaryon will also be on the side of
rhaenyra and daemon during the dance of
dragons
in fact we will see him and daemon win
some battles during this first season
rhaenara actually marries his son lenore
although lehnor doesn't have much
interest in women if you know what i
mean
speaking of lenore this is who we see
next walking in with his father lord
corliss velaryon as well as his mother
rhaenys targaryen who is a dragon rider
herself i might add i actually can't
believe some fans are upset with hbo
hiring steve as lord corless valerion i
think he looks badass easily one of the
most interesting looking characters in
the whole show
now it looks as if they're walking into
some sort of feast maybe even a wedding
feast given they are all dressed in this
glamorous gold you can also see king
viserys targaryen and his daughter
rhaenyra sitting at the head of the
table at the end of the hall
now i believe this next character we see
here is masaria the mistress of whispers
she also has a romantic relationship
with daemon targaryen as well
she will be sort of like the varus of
house of the dragon next we see allison
hightower running with what looks like a
valyrian steel dagger the same valyrian
steel dagger arya stark used to kill the
night king i love that we will be seeing
some of the old weapons and locations
again now i'm not exactly sure what she
is running at but if you look behind her
you can also see the lore commander of
the kingsguard sir harold westerling in
the next few shots we see what looks
like a jousting tournament most likely
during the same few scenes we saw
earlier where the knights were throwing
down in the yard then we see lenore
velaryon again i think this is at his
ancestral home of driftmark given the
image on the wall i honestly have no
idea what's happening in this scene i'm
not sure who that other character is
either
let me know down below if you know
what's happening here in the scene
now i want to move on to the final few
shots this final scene is amazing and i
was actually stunned when i saw this
here we have our money shot of the new
iron throne now it still isn't exactly
like it is described in the books but it
does look much better than the last one
the new iron throne has so many more
swords which i absolutely love i
actually can't believe we are seeing new
scenes in this room again it almost
feels like this day would never come but
now it finally feels real we are about
to be back in westeros once again and i
for one cannot wait i happen to think
all of the actors look amazing i also
think all the sets and locations look
incredible everything looks and feels
exactly how it should if you ask me
i am very happy with what we have seen
so far
now we just have to wait a few more
months until we can actually start
watching this new show let me know down
below if you're excited for house of the
dragon i was actually just finishing up
on my next episode of game of thrones
season 9. i almost have that video done
but as soon as i saw this i had to set
the video aside so i can give some of my
thoughts about the new teaser trailer as
always let me know what you think about
everything down below also let me know
if there is anything i missed i will
definitely be watching this video again
and again for now i want to thank all of
you for stopping by and checking out my
video i hope all of you have a great day
i will see you again very soon
[Music]
[Music]
you